well it yeah we become an Academy member  then you get the vote and it's it you  feel responsibility I think everyone  feels this great responsibility and I  feel it and then I want to make sure I  see all the films I can and see them the  best way I can but I'm not very good at  watching a film and analyzing what parts  are good and be really bad to me to see  if to watch a film and start analyzing  the costume design or the sound design  so if the film's good I forget all that  stuff and I have to think about it  afterwards and yeah it kind of work so I  certainly don't want to and I don't go  into good movies thinking about even  what I and my part of it I don't I don't  recognize great sound jobs in great  movies right away because I just taken  the great movie and then think oh that's  pretty good that's the way I I what I  like about movies is getting lost in  them and forgetting or watching a movie  and so approaching it like a voter is a  post mortem  job to me